[Music]
the scrolls are set to make their big
screen debut in this year's new MCU
movie captain marvel this alien race has
plagued our heroes and the comics for
decades now and they always provide a
thrilling showdown but who are they what
are their powers and ultimately their
end goals well throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the scrolls on
and off the page there will be some
spoilers here in relation to their
appearance in the comic books so if you
don't want to know anything then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
don't forget to stick around until the
end to hear my fan theory on which MCU
Avengers team member could secretly be
one but with that out the way
i'm definition and welcome to the
channel where i watch it so you don't
have to the scrolls first appeared as
early as 1961 in Fantastic Four issue 2
titled and the scrolls attack Earth this
issue introduced the alien race who set
out to destroy the Fantastic Four and
eventually conquer the earth
luckily the Fantastic Four managed to
stop them capture them and even went so
far as to hypnotize them to believe that
they were cows those who read civil war
will know that this eventually led to
more mutants being created due to them
drinking their milk and having Skrull
cow burgers for that stories for another
day the Skrulls themselves were created
by Jack Kirby and Stan Lee who
throughout the years built upon their
backstory and origins so how exactly did
they come to be well millions of years
ago on the planet scroll of the
Celestials performed genetic experiments
on reptilian ancestors of the scrolls
and this caused three forms of the
creatures to be born these were called
the prime the deviants and the Eternals
however the three races were enabled to
coexist with one another and this
eventually came to a head with the
deviants wiping out the majority of the
other
races until only the scroll eternal and
the prime scroll were left
unlike the deviants neither of those
races were able to shape-shift so they
could not compete with their more
modified cousins the two survivors of
their respective races eventually fell
in love and the two became gods to the
deviants ruling over them with the goal
of expanding their territory throughout
the galaxy so what are their powers
beyond shape-shifting well there are
elite versions of the scrolls known as
the war Scrolls and the infamous super
Scrolls
these are able to replicate the powers
of various Marvel heroes however unlike
their brethren depending on what
continuity you read they cannot change
shift so in the end you either have very
strong scrolls that possess insane
powers or weaker ones that don't but can
transform eventually the scrolls
developed interstellar travel which
threw them into their first major comic
book arc the kree-skrull war the book
opens with Captain Marvel a Kree hero
who in this story is a male arriving on
earth from the negative zone it turns
out that the Kree and scroll have
battled one another for millennia but
that the conflict had died down
unfortunately Ronan the accuser manages
to reignite the war and the Avengers
become involved due to their affiliation
with Captain Marvel in the story it's
revealed an allied to the Avengers rift
Jones has vast mental powers and manages
to freeze all of the combatants in this
war and this showcases that humanity has
earned that potential from this conflict
another big Marvel character hulk Ling
is produced who is a Kree Skrull hybrid
the Skrulls will go on to feature in
many comics including infiltrating earth
his second crease crow war and secret
invasion in secret invasion the scrolls
even manage to infiltrate earth on
several levels they were even successful
in replacing a large chunk of the Marvel
heroes and this reveal came as a huge
twist and the MCU I think that this is
already come into play with one of the
major Avengers being a scroll since
their second appearance which I'll go
into now okay firstly before I go into
this I just want to preface it with the
fact that marble themselves have said
numerous times that there may already be
Scrolls in the MCU and this is why they
feature as the villain
based on this information I personally
believe that rody is a scroll a to to a
number of reasons firstly judging from
an external point of view it's unlikely
that Kevin Feige and the headset Marvel
would want one of the main movie
frontrunners to be one as this would
retroactively litchi pin their movies
and maybe make it seem like they weren't
the heroes that we will idolize growing
up secondly rody has already went
through a major change in the movies in
Iron Man the actor was played by
Terrence Howard before being changed to
Don Cheadle so if it was introduced that
he was captured upon the appearance of
Iron Man his change in appearance would
make a lot of sense some scrolls also
have psychic abilities so they could
ultimately make those around Rhodey
believe that nothing was out of place
rody is also pretty pedestrian
throughout the franchise sure he helps
out in battle but how much does he
actually offer when it comes to strategy
and fighting the big bad
not much he's actually the perfect
person to be a mole as he not only fits
in nicely with the US government able to
gain secrets on their Intel excetera but
he's also infiltrated the Avengers so it
be able to monitor their moves too
lastly Rhodey never rocks the boat the
only time that he really took a stance
against something was in infinity war
when he defied general Ross but his race
was in danger then too so it makes sense
that would step up to the position the
fact that the scrolls that are able to
shape-shift don't possess any other
powers also gives him motive for why he
wants to take the mark to prototype in
Hindman 2 and kick this out with his own
weaponry now he is blended in and can
compete with the rest of the team due to
suits ability and it would be great if
this was a big twist in the MCU as it
harkens back to the first film so that's
everything you need to know about the
scrolls before you check out this year's
MCU movies obviously we will see if this
comes to fruition in Captain Marvel and
Avengers endgame but personally I think
it would really be a great twist and it
makes a lot of sense I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the scrolls and if
you're excited to see them appear in the
MCU and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the top three
theories on Captain Marvel which would
be linked at the end this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]